[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم عثمان اي
فرح وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى من انقر نتابع هذه الصور
المباشره بعد فرز مئه في المئه من الاصوات
واعلان هيئه الانتخابات التركيه النتائج
غير النهائيه لسباق الرئاسه حيث تتجه
تركيا نحو جوله اعاده الانتخابات الى
السودان وتحديدا اندرمان التي تعيش على
وقع اشتباكات متفرقه بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع اما هذه هي صور فتصلنا
من العاصمه البريطانيه لندن في خضم زياره
زيلينسكي الرئيس الاوكراني في اعقاب
زيارات اجراها الى روما وبرلين وباريس حيث
تلقى تعهدات بتزويد بلاده بمسيرات هجوميه
وصواريخ ارض جوي
وفي مواضيع الاعصاب هذه الليله
[موسيقى]
بعد عدم تخطي اي من المرشحين عتبه الخمسين
في المئه من الاصوات تركيا تتجه الى جوله
ثانيه للانتخابات الرئاسيه لاول مره في
تاريخ الجمهوريه وتحالف حزب العداله
والتنميه يحافظ على اغلبيته في البرلمان
المواجهات في السودان تدخل شهرها الثاني
اشتباكات متفرقه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع في مناطق جنوب الخرطوم وام درمان
ومرحله ثانيه من المفاوضات بين طرفي
الاقتتال بحضور ممثلين للوساطه الامريكيه
السعوديه ومع اتساع المواجهات في غرب
دارفور حاكم الاقليم يقول ان المكونات
الرسميه هناك تنائى بنفسها عن القتال
كيف تعلن تحقيق ما اعتبرته اول نجاحا في
هجومها في محيط باخموت وروسيا تقول انها
تتقدم في المدينه
وبعد جوله اوروبيه زيلينسكي يحصل على مزيد
من الاسلحه من بريطانيا تتضمن طائرات
مسيره هجوميه بعيده المدى البيت الابيض
يقول ان ايران وروسيا توسعان تعاونهم
العسكريه غير المسبوق وكيف تستقبل
الثلاثاء مفردا صينيا لبحث فرص التسويه
[موسيقى]
بعد اسبوع من الاضطرابات في باكستان
تحذيرات شديده لهجه من الجيش عشيه اجتماع
للقيادات الامنيه والسياسيه لبحث الاوضاع
في البلاد سنحاكم الضالعين في تخريب منشات
عسكريه ولن نمارس ضبط النفس واحتجاجات على
وقع مثور عمران خان امام القضاء مجددا
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا اتجاه تركيا في جوله اعاده
للانتخابات الرئاسيه بعد ان اعلن رئيس
اللجنه العليا للانتخابات عدم تخطي اي من
المرشحين الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان ومنافسه
كمال كريستار اوغلو عتمه الخمسين في المئه
من الاصوات المطلوبه للفوز من المرحله
الاولى باستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع
كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي في
رايكم ما هي اسباب ذهاب تركيا لجوله اعاده
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه 14% عزو ذلك
لتعقيدات المشهد الداخلي بينما
47% راوا ان الاسباب تكمن في تشكيل جبهه
معارضه موحده اما 39% فقالوا انها تعود
لحده الاستقطاب السياسي
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهره على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا كيف احيا
الفلسطينيون ذكرى مرور 75 عاما على النكبه
تخوض تركيا للمره الاولى في تاريخها جوله
ثانيه للانتخابات الرئاسيه في اعقاب دوره
اولى شهدت منافسه محتدمه بين الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان الذي حصل على نسبه
49.50% ومنافسه الرئيسي كمال كريشدار
اوغلو الذي حقق 45%
انتخابات التركيه التي وصفت بالمصريه دون
ان تحدد مصير البلاد
[موسيقى]
قالت هذه الصناديق كلمتها فمنح التحالف
الجمهور الذي يقوده حزب العداله والتنميه
الحاكم فوزا مريحا في البرلمان لكنها لم
تحسم فوز زعيم الحزب الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
بالرغم من تقدمه بفارق كبير عن منافسه
مرشح المعارضه كما الكليج دارول
وفقا للقانون الانتخابي لم يفز اي من
المرشحين في الانتخابات الرئاسيه وعليه
قررنا عقد جوله ثانيه يوم 28 من مايو
الجاري الصحف المقربه من الحكومه رات ان
اراده الشعب تجلت في هذه النتائج عندما
منحت اردوغان اصواتا بفارق وصل الى نحو
مليونين ونصف مليون صوت عن منافسه بينما
رات صحف المعارضه ان الرجل خسر هذه
الانتخابات بل واتهم الحكومه بمحاوله
التلاعب في النتائج لكن يبقى ان عوامل عده
حرمت اردوغان الفوز من الجوله الاولى في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه وافقدته اسطنبول
والعاصمه انقره اكبر المدن التركيه وهو
الذي لطالما حصل على النسبه الاكبر من
اصوات المدينتين
الاقتصاد والزلزال في تركيا اضرار الحكومه
بشكل كبير لكن جهودها الكبيره في دعم
المتضررين من الزلزال اقنعتهم بالتصويت
بشكل كبير للتحالف الجمهور اما الغلاء
والتضخم وخصوصا في المدن الكبرى فجعلك
كثيرا من الناخبين وخصوصا الشباب يفضلون
البديل
اكثر من خمسه في المئه حصل عليها المرشح
القومي سنان اوران في هذه الانتخابات لا
شك انها ستلعب الدوره الحاسمه في تحديد
نتيجه الجوله الثانيه الامر الذي يرى فيه
كثير من المراقبين ان مزيجا من الناخبين
القوميين ومن العلمانيين الغاضبين من
انسحاب مرشحهم محرم انجاح بشكل مفاجئ قبل
عده ايام من الانتخابات سيكون رمانه
القبان في هذه الجوله يقول حزب العداله
والتنميه انه حقق انتصاره السادس عشر على
التوالي في تاريخه لكنه يبدو انتصارا
منقوصا هذه المره سيقود الحزب الى مواجهه
جديده محتدمه ستتداخل فيها عوامل خارجيه
وداخليه عده قبل ان يحسم الاسم الذي سيقود
البلاد خلال السنوات الخمس المقبله امرنا
في الجزيره اسطنبول
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان اكد ان
كوادر ولجان حزبه سيواصلون العمل بلا توقف
لضمان الفوز في جوله الاعاده جاء ذلك في
تغريده نشرها عقب اجتماعه باعضاء اللجنه
المركزيه لحزب العداله والتنميه في انقره
وشكر اردوغان الشعب التركي او المشاركين
في الانتخابات الذين بلغ عددهم 56 مليونا
على ما اسماه المشاركه الفاعله والقويه في
الانتخابات ووعد الرئيس التركي جمهوره
الانتخابي انهم سيخرجون منتصرين ليله
الثامن والعشرين من مايو ايار الجاري في
اشاره لتاريخ جوله الاعاده
في المقابل قال المرشح الرئاسي عن تحالف
الشعب كمال كريجدار اوغلو في فيديو قصير
نشره على صفحته في موقع تويتر انه جاهز
للكفاح مع انصاره حتى النهايه حسب تعبيره
انا هنا انا هنا وانتم معي ايضا هنا اقسم
انني ساكافح حتى النهايه
ينضم الينا من انقره مراسل الجزيره المعتز
بالله حسن المعتز بعد ساعات طويله طويله
النتيجه النهائيه خرجت فرزت 100% من هذه
الاصوات كيف تبدو مستجدات هذه الساعات
الماضيه وردود الفعل على هذه النتيجه
[موسيقى]
هذا النصر بحسب اردوغان هو كان منذ يوم
امس لوجود فارق مليونين ونصف مليون الصوت
ولكن
سيكون هناك عمل اكثر
للخروج بما
بنتيجه
يرضى عنها الشارع كما قال او انها تكون
جيده له لحزبه في المقابل حزب الشعب
الجمهوري رئيس حزب الشعب الجمهوري شاهدناه
اليوم في فيديو عبر تغريده يضرب يده
بالطاوله ويقول انه جاهز للمواجهه هذه
المواجهه التي ستكون ايضا مواجهه صعبه
وفيها الكثير من الحسابات فيما يتعلق
بالتحالفات خصوصا وان القوى التي تتواجد
في كل تحالف هي قوى ربما هناك نسبه
الاصوات الموجوده
للمرشح الرئاسي السابق محرم انجا وايضا
المرشح الرئاسي السابق سنان اوغان كيف
سيكون توزيع هذه هل سيصوت من صوت لهما لكل
لاي من كريشدار اوغلو او رجب طيب اردوغان
كل هذه هي حسابات في الجوله الثانيه التي
ستكون بعد 15 يوما او في 28 من الشهر
الحالي نتطلع الى ذلك اعتقد من تابع هذه
الليله الماضيه في الانتخابات سوف يتابع
حاتما ايضا يوم الثامن والعشرين موعد جوله
الاعاده شكرا للمعتز بالله حسن من انقره
وارحب بمحيي الدين اتمنى الباحث في مركز
الدراسات السياسيه والاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه ومن اسطنبول سيحان افجار
الكاتبه الصحفيه في جريده جمهوريه اهلا
وسهلا بكم وابدا منك سيده اسيحان لماذا
ذهبت تركيا لجوله ثانيه لاول مره في
تاريخها ما الذي ادى الى ذلك في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه
هل ابدا انا
السؤال لماذا ذهبت تركيا الى جوله ثانيه
لاول مره في تاريخها الاسباب التي ادت الى
ذلك
السؤال موجه الي نعم مرحبا ومساء الخير
لماذا تركيا
تتوجه نحو الجوله الثانيه يوم امس
المصادف لاربعه عشره مايو وقد توجه
[موسيقى]
ست
وثمانون مليون كان مهتم بذلك وقد تم
التصويت بين ايضا
[موسيقى]
المرشحين
كذلك وقد حصل
تحالف الجمهور على
49.5 بالمئه ثم كما الكل اشتروا قد حصل
على المركز الثاني وربما كانت المفاجاه
5.7% الذي كان للسنان اوغون ثم نجدوه بانه
قد
[موسيقى]
انتقلت الانتخابات الى جولهها بسبب عدم
الحصول ايا من
المرشحين على خمسين بالمئه زائد فاصل ونجد
بان استطلاعات الراي والشركات المعنيه
بذلك
اخطات في توقعاتها وفي واقع الامر ان
السنن اوهان الذي قاله بانه اذا ما استطاع
ان يفوز بالانتخابات سوف يقوم بارجاع
وترضي المهاجرين وكانوا يقولون بان من
يقول بذلك فانه سيكون فاشل وانما رايناه
انه حصل على اصوات متقدمه وبالتالي فان
مرشح
تحالف الجمهور لم يستطع ايضا ان يحقق 50
بالمئه ولهذا السبب
[موسيقى]
الان تم تقرر اجراء الجوله الثانيه من
الانتخابات طيب سيد محي الدين أتمان هل
بدات المحادثات
لاستقطاب ربما لتحالفات جديده ربما للحصول
على تاييد المرشح الثالث وهو سنان اوغان
لا اعتقد بان سنان اوغنن سيلعب دورا مؤثرا
في الجوله الثانيه والسبب الرئيسي يعود
الى اننا عندما ننظر الى نسبه اصوات رجب
طيب اردوغان انه في واقي الامر كان قريب
جدا من النصاب وقد انتقل الى الجوله
الثانيه وبالتالي ان جزءا كبيرا من
المؤيدين
لسنن اوغنن هم في واقي الامر من القومين
والشباب الذين لم يريدوا التصويت لاردون
ولكن بطبيعتهم لا يمكن ان يؤيدوا كلش فان
سبب زياده اصوات سنان هو تركيزه على
مكافحه الارهاب ومكافحه المنظمتين
الارهابيتين لفيتو
وحزب العمال
وبالتالي نجد انه داخل
ايضا الشعب هناك ساسه مناصرين لتنظيم غلام
الارهابي ومناصرين ايضا ربما
نعم القوميه الكرديه اليمين المتطرفه وحتى
الارهابيه وبالتالي احتمال ان يصوت مؤيد
سنن اوغان تحالف الشعب وطالما هذه هي
الحقيقه بانني اعتقد بان الذين
[موسيقى]
هؤلاء سيذهبون الى صناديق الاقتراع بشكل
جيد وليست هناك حاجه الى دعم سنان اوغان
في واقي الامر ولا اعتقد ان تحالف الشعب
ايضا سيتساوم مع السيناب في هذه الحاله هل
تعتقدين ان اي المرشحين الرئيس اردوغان او
كريستيانو سوف يسعى الاستقطاب
الاصوات التي ذهبت الى سنان اوغان وهل
تعتقدين ان ذلك ممكن وكيف
النظام اعتقد ان هناك احتمال كبير بان
يكون الجلوس مع سنان اوغان للجوله الثانيه
نعتقد ان كلا طرفين سيجلس مع السنان وقد
راينا بعض المعلومات وخاصه في الكواليس
ايضا وان
ايضا
كمال اتصل مباشره بسنان اوغانم بعد
الاعلان عن النتائج لتهنئته على ذلك ويمكن
ان ندرس ونقرا عفوا هذا الموضوع بانه
بادره او مؤشر اولي
لان
تحالف الشعب سيتواصل مع السنان اوغان ولا
شك انه سيتم طرق باب بسنان اوغان وستكون
هناك بعض المساومات فبالتالي يمكن
الاقتراح على سنان اوغان تولي وزارات مهمه
مثلا ان يكون وزير الداخليه ربما الوقت
مبكر جدا وربما سيتم عرض
عليه بعض المقترحات
المهمه ايضا وخاصه فيما يتعلق يمكن
التوقيع مع السنان اوغنن على بروتوكول
ارجاع نعم اللاجئين والمهاجرين الى
بلدانهم في حال فوز
تحالف
الشعب وانا اقول ان كل من تحالف الشعب
وايضا تحالف الجمهور مضطر للتواصل مع سنان
اوغان للانتصار والفوز في الجوله الثانيه
وبدا التربه المشاورات ربما من الان قد
تكون قد تبدو فرص الرئيس اردوغان اكبر من
نظيره كريجدار اوغلو ولكن ايضا هو لم يحصل
على مكانه يسعى اليه وبالتالي سيدمان هل
هو مستعد للتقديم ربما بعض التنازلات كيف
سوف يسعى الاستقطاب مزيد من الاصوات التي
لم تصوت له في الجوله الاولى
لابد من التاكيد على انه في حال التوجه
الى الجوله الثانيه ان
تاريخ السياسه التركيه قد شهد ربما اكبر
نسبه من المشاركه في الانتخابات وانا
اعتقد ان الجوله الثانيه ستشهد نوعا من
التراجع في الاقبال لماذا لانني ارى بان
هناك خيبه امل طابعه على المؤيدين
لتحالف المعارضه ويقولون
نسبه فوز كريشنال الضئيل جدا في الجوله
الثانيه وهذا
محسوم تقريبا او شبه محسوم وبالتالي ان
الناخب
للمعارضه هو فقد امله وربما سيعزف ومن
المحتمل ان
يعزف عدد كبير من الناخبين عن التوجه الى
صناديق التصويت الاقتراع ايضا هو من ناحيه
اخرى
نجد داخل الاحزاب الاخرى المنضويه تحت
تحالف الشعب الامر نفسه اما عندما ننظر
الى تحالف الجمهور الذي
يترعزه اردوغان فاضمن ستكون هناك جهود
مبذوله من اجل الحصول على فارق كبير في
الجوله الثانيه واعتقد ان نتائج الجوله
الثانيه ستكون متميزه عن الجوله الاولى
بفارق كبير بين
المتنافسين يعني اعتقد ان الفارق سيكون
اكثر مما هو عليه الان بنقاط عده شكرا
جزيلا لكم من انقره محي الدين اتمنى
الباحث في مركز الدراسات السياسيه والا
قتصاديه والاجتماعيه ومن اسطنبول سيحان
افشار الكاتبه في صحيفه جمهوريه
[موسيقى]
في السودان مع مرور شهر على الاشتباكات
المسلحه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
يتواصل القتال في العاصمه الخرطوم تحديدا
وسط اتهامات متبادله بقصف احياء مدنيه
وقرارات من رئيس مجلس السياده باقاله
مسؤولين وترقب لنتائج الجوله الثانيه من
المباحثات في جده
المشهد ذاته في السودان تتكرس مشاهد
القتال بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
للشهر الثاني على التوالي طبق الخرطوم
عنوان هذا القتال ينحصر اطلاق النار في
مركز العاصمه تقريبا حيث المقر السياديه
للبلاد يقصف الجيش مواقع للدعم في العاصمه
يقول انه تعامل مع امدادات اللوجستيه
كبيره من الاسلحه والذخائر والوقود يرد
الدعم السريع باتهام الجيش بقصف مناطق
ماهوله بالمدنيين منها مستشفى شرق النيل
بالعاصمه هكذا يريد كل طرف ان يثبت اقدامه
في العاصمه ساعيا نحو قلب موازين السيطره
العسكريه مع دخول المعارك شهره الثاني
يصدر رئيس مجلس السياده قائد الجيش قرارات
جديده يعفي البرهان وزير الداخليه المكلف
ومدير عام الشرطه وينهي خدمه سفيرين
بوزاره الخارجيه دون توضيح الاسباب يحيل
من التقاعد ضباط في الجيش كانوا منتدبين
لدى قوات السريع قبل اندلاع الازمه من بين
هؤلاء رئيس وفد الدعم السريع في محادثات
جده يذهب البرهان ابعد من ذلك يضيق الخناق
ماديا على حميتي وقواته بتجميد حسابات
الدعم في البنوك داخل وخارج البلاد بعد ان
كان قد اقال محافظا للبنك المركزي كل ذلك
والاعين نحو جده هناك بدات المرحله
الثانيه من المحادثات بين طرفي القتال
كانت المرحله الاولى قد بدات بعد ثلاثه
اسابيع من اندلاع الازمه اتفق المتقاتلون
فيها على اعلان مبادئ لحمايه المدنيين
وتجنب وقوعهم في دائره الخطر في الجوله
الثانيه الحاليه يحضر ممثلون عن الوساطه
الامريكيه السعوديه يمكن ان يتم الاتفاق
على وقف دائم لاطلاق النار تتم مراقبته
عبر الاقمار الاصطناعيه من الدول الراعيه
للمباحثات بالاضافه لامكانيه وجود مراقبين
على الارض من الاتحاد الافريقي كل هذه
التفاصيل موافقه مصدر سوداني مطلع صرح بها
للجزيره قبل جلسات جده وبعدها اتفق
الطرفان على عده هدن لكنها لم تفضي الى
توقف القتال او رسم ملامح حل للازمه
احاديث القتال والسيطره على الميدان
توازيها احاديث المفاوضات وتفاصيل الهدى
ووقف اطلاق النار من كل ذلك وفق
السودانيين والوضع الانساني
قرابه 250 انسانا قتلوا واصيب اكثر من
ثلاثه الاف في الخرطوم وحدها خلال شهر من
المعارك لكن خلال يومين فقط قتل اكثر من
280 في اشتباكات بولايه دارفور غربيه
البلاد اذ تفيد نقابه الاطباء السودانيه
بانهيار كامل للنظام الصحي في مدينه
الجنينه عاصمه ولايه غرب دارفور
هكذا يبقى المشهد على حاله في السودان 30
يوما من القتال لم توقفها المناشدات
الدوليه ولا المفاوضات الجاريه تصبح الان
واحدا وثلاثين يوما ولا يبدو ان العد
سيتوقف هنا
معنى من جنوب الخرطوم الجزيره طاهر المرضي
وانضم الينا من جده مراسل الجزيره بدر
ربيعان طاهر ابدا بك ما هي اخر المستجدات
في العاصمه السودانيه
نعم اخر المستجدات هو تجدد الاشتباكات وان
كانت قد تراجعت الاشتباكات المباشره على
الارض فقد زادت حده الاشتباكات بالطيران
الحربي في مواقع مختلفه خاصه وان اليوم
كانت هنالك قاره جويه على في شرق النيل
على مستشفى الشرق النيل هذا المستشفى في
محيط هذا المستشفى يقول الجيش السوداني
انه استهدف امداد بالذخيره وكذلك الوقود
ومجموعه من قوات الدعم السريع في هذا
المكان التي حاولت ان تتخذ منه موقعا
للارتكاز في موقع للارتكاز وقالت انه قد
كبدت قوات الدعم السريع خسائر فادحه بينما
اصدر قواته واصدرت قوات الدعم السريع
بيانا تقول ان القاره الجويه قد اودت
بحياه كثير من المدنيين هذا هو الواقع في
تبادل الاتهامات بين الطرفين وايضا هنالك
تحليق للطيران وكذلك
المضادات الارضيه لقوات الدعم السريه ترد
بكثافه في مواقع مختلفه في العاصمه
السودانيه بينما
الاعلان الموقع بين بين الطرفين اعلان جده
لم يكن فعال اي لم يطبق بشكل الذي يمكن ان
يحقق حمايه للمدنيين سواء كان في المجال
الانساني او مجهلات
اعاده فتح المستشفيات التي تاثرت بهذه
الاشتباكات او محاوله ازاله الارتكازات في
الشوارع الرئيسيه في الخرطوم وهذا تاثير
كبير على النواحي الانسانيه بالنسبه
للمواطنين خاصه وان هذه الحرب التي تدخل
الشهر الثاني تلقي بظلال كثيفه على
الاوضاع الانسانيه بالنسبه للخرطوم السلعه
الض
السيوله امكانيه التحرك بسلام والتنقل
وخاصه وهذا ما النص عليه اتفاق الجده
ولذلك نجد ان الانظار تتجه الى جده لكي
يكون هنالك وقف لاطلاق النار ولو كان لمده
قصيره ومتماسكه ووجود رقابه على الارض
يعني هذا يعني ان هذه الاتفاقات يمكن ان
تكون لها يعني جوانب ايجابيه على الاوضاع
بالنسبه للمواطنين من ناحيه الانسانيه
وبالتالي تصبح الامور كلها معلقه في ان
يكون هذا الحوار بين الطرفين يفضي الى
نتائج ايجابيه يمكن ان تعدل السلام على
الارض خاصه وان هذه الحرب اتسعت دائرتها
وشملت ايضا ولايه غرب دارفور حيث قتل
المئات هناك بسبب هذه الحوار المتوسعه
اليوم في مدينه الرهد بولايه شمال
وهذه الامور يخشى البعض يعني
كذلك المباحثات التي يتحدث عنها هي في جده
الامل عليها كما قال الطاهر المرضي بدر
هذه هي المرحله الثانيه
بحضور وسطات سعوديين وامريكيين كيف تسير
المرحله الثانيه من المباحثات
نعم نعم عثمان نتحدث عن يوم ثاني من هذه
المباحثات في جولتها الثانيه التي انطلقت
صباح امس برعايه السعوديه امريكيه وبحضور
المبعوث الامم السوداني الاضافه الى ممثلي
الرباعيه الدوليه مرحله جديده للمباحثات
يعني هدفها البحث في ترتيبات تنفيذ اعلان
جده على ارض الواقع بما فيها مده التنفيذ
وفتح الممرات الانسانيه وايضا تشكيل لجنه
لتثبت من تنفيذ الالتزامات اضافه الى عدد
من البرود التي وقع عليها الطرفان في
اعلان جده ايضا هذه المباحثات المستمره
وفقا لمسؤول في وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
تهدف الى دراسه الاليات الممكنه لانهاء
النزاع بالسوداني اضافه الى مقترح هدنه
قصيره لمده خمسه ايام للتوقيع عليها بجانب
ملفات اخرى حقيقه لا يوجد سقف زمري محدد
لهذه المباحثات والتي تجري بشكل غير مباشر
حيث يتم نقل ما يقوله طرف النزاع الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع على الوسطاء
عبر الوسطاء الذين يقومون على هذه الملف
والذين حثوا الطرفين على استشعار
المسؤوليه وانخراط بجديه في المحادثات
وخلق مناخ ايجابي لها حقيقه اعلان جدا كان
خطوه ايجابيه باتجاه على الاقل وضع ارضيه
لنوع من التفاهمات بين الطرفين يلتزمان
فيه بالاعراف الدوليه والانتباه ايضا الى
ان حمايه المدنيين في قائمه الاولويات قبل
ان تكون مسؤوليه المجتمع الدولي وكذلك
يؤطر العمل العسكري لاطراف النزاع على
الارض بعيدا عن النزاع الغير منضبط مطار
انساني وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل
بن فرحان كان اشاره الى المحادثات واعلان
الالتزام بحمايه المدنيين جاء كخطوه اولى
ستتبعها خطوات اخرى وتخلي حديثه ايضا اشار
الى اهميه التزام الطرفين بما تم الاتفاق
عليه من بنود والتزامات في
الاعلان الذي يعلن عنه اولا من امس اذا ما
تحدثنا عن اصحاب المبادره السعوديون
الامريكيون من الواضح انهم جادون في وضع
ملامح وخارطه الطريق للخروج من هذه الازمه
على الصعيد الانساني والسياسي والعسكري
حتى الان حقيقه هناك تكتم في مسار عمليه
المباحثات للتجري هنا في مقر وزاره
الخارجيه بجده توقفت يوم واحد ثم عادت
من جديد وهناك حرص على ان تستمر حتى تحقق
هدفها الرئيسي بمفاوضات موسعه وانهاء
النزاع السوداني الذي دخل اسبوعه الرابع
ووقف دائم للاطلاق النار يتفق عليه الطرفه
النزاع الذي يجلسون على طاوله المباحثات
التمهيديه تستهدف وزاره الخارجيه هنا الى
جعلها وترقيتها الى مباحثات وتفاوضات
موسعه هنا في جده شكرا جزيلا لكم بدر
الربيعة في جده والطهر المرضي في الخرطوم
قال حاكم اقليم دارفور مني مناوي ان
المكونات الرئيسيه والاهليه في اربع
ولايات في اقليم دارفور قررت عدم الدخول
في اي حرب وطلب من ناوي من دول الجوار فتح
حدودها لاستقبال الجرحى ومصابيه
الاشتباكات القبليه في مدينه الجنينه
وكانت اخر تلك المواجهات قد اندلعت يومي
الجمعه والسبت الماضيين وخلفت مئات القتلى
والجرحى حسب نقابه الاطباء السودانيه
هائل وماساوي ذاك الذي يحدث في مدينه
الجنينه السودانيه وهو اكبر من ان يحجبه
دخان المعارك في الخرطوم
فاستنادا الى مصادر صحيه بينها نقابه
الاطباء السودانيه ادت اعمال العنف
الدائره في المدينه الى مقتل 280 شخصا على
الاقل واصابه اكثر من 160 بجروح وتلك قد
لا تكون حصيله النهائيه بالنظر الى
الصعوبات التي تعترض عمليه احصاء الضحايا
اضافه الى انهيار النظام الصحي حتى ان
حاكم اقليمي دارفور طالبت تشاد بفتح
الحدود
دعوتنا لاخواننا واخواتنا في دول الجوار
من الشات نتمنى بان تفتح لنا حدودها ل عدد
كبير جدا من الجرحى ما زالوا لمده اكثر من
ثلاثه اسابيع لم يجدوا علاج في الجنينه
لذلك نحن ندعوهم وفي نفس الدعاء وفي نفس
الدعوه بندعوا معانا المنظمات المحليه
والاقليميه والدوليه جميعا بان تسعفنا
وتساعدنا بانسياب المواط
الطبيه تقول نقابه الاطباء ومصادر محليه
في الجنينه ان ميليشيا قبليه مسلحه يرتدي
مقاتلوها زي قوات الدعم السريع هاجمت فجر
الجمعه عده احياء في المدينه ومراكز ايواء
النازحين مستخدمه الاسلحه الثقيله
وتعد الجنينه التي تقع في اقصى غرب
السودان من اكبر المدن السودانيه وهي مركز
ولايه غرب دارفور وتبعد عن مدينه الخرطوم
الف ومئتين كيلومتر ويبلغ عدد سكان جنينه
اكثر من 170 الف نسمه وفق احصاءات قديمه
وتسكنها قبائل اف ريقيه وعربيه
وبين تلك القبائل عداء مستحكم تمتد جذوره
الى ما قبل احداث دارفور وقد تحول مرارا
الى اقتتال مسلح لا سيما في السنوات
الاخيره
واليوم يشتد ذلك الصراع القبلي اكثر فاكثر
مدفوعا بالمواجهات بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع واحداث الجنينه
الاخيره هذه قد لا تكون الا امتدادا لتلك
المواجهات التي تدخل شعرها الثاني
[موسيقى]
اطلقت صافرات الحداد
الصافات الحداد
اطلقت وتوقفت الحركه مده 75 ثانيه في
مختلف المدن الفلسطينيه ايذانا ببدء
فعاليات احياء الذكرى الخامسه والسبعين
للنكبه وشارك الاف الفلسطينيين في مسيره
مركزيه في مدينه رام الله رافعين الاعلام
الفلسطينيه واسماء اكثر من 500 قريه
دمرتها القوات الاسرائيليه عام 1948
[موسيقى]
وتعود ذكر النكبه الفلسطينيه ولا تزال
سيره الصراع مع الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هي هي
تاتي والضحايا في غزه لما تجف دمائهم بعد
من اخر اعتداء اسرائيلي على القطاع وهو ما
يجعل النكبه صيروره في الماساه الفلسطينيه
اكثر منها ذكرى ومع تراجع الحديث عن
السلام وعن الدوله الفلسطينيه لم يبقى من
مقاربه للتعاطي مع الصراع غير المتكافئ
بين الفلسطينيين وبين جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الا مصطلحي التهدئه والتصعيد
وهو تكتيك دبلوماسي لا يقول شيئا في
المحصله النهائيه غير ابقاء الوضع على ما
هو عليه انه اصطلاح مؤبد للاحتلال مصادر
بحق المقاومه في ان تقول لا انه اصطلاح
مؤبد للنكبه نتابع معا تقرير فوزي بشرى
[موسيقى]
وانتهى مشهد اخر من القتل ومن الدمار ومن
التضحيات مشهد من سيره الحرب على قطاع غزه
من سيره النكبه التي كانت ولم تزل هل
تختلف مشاهد القصف بين حرب وحرب الا
بمقدار الاختلاف بين قتل وقتل ويتمن
الا تتشابه مواكب الشهداء بين امس واليوم
الشهداء الذين يمنحون للموت معنى الحياه
والقضيه الفلسطينيه معنى ان تبقى حيه قضيه
تقلق الضمير الانسانيه وان تعامى عنها ليس
بوصفها ذكرى لنكبه حدثت عام 48
غضت بتواطؤ دولي ان تلقي شعبا من الوجود
وان تبعث اخر
الاعتداء الاسرائيلي الاخير على غزه الذي
اغتال عددا من القاده في سرايا القدس
الجناح العسكري للجهاد الاسلامي ودمر وقتل
واصاب بنا المدنيين ما اصاب هو فصل من
تاريخ متصل على مدى خمسه وسبعين عاما منذ
كانت العصابات تقتل وتحرق وتستبيح البدن
والبلدات الفلسطينيه لتصنع دولتها على
حساب الفلسطيني وتصنع مشروع امنها وحياتها
على ارهاب الفلسطيني
ودفعه الى اللجوء والنزوح قصه النكبه امس
هي قصتها اليوم
ومعادله امس هي معادلتها اليوم سلام
اسرائيل وتوسعها مرتبط ارتباطا عضويا بقتل
الفلسطيني وارحابه وسجنه ودفعه الى حواف
العدم باقتلاعه من الارض
خمسه ايام غزه الاخيره ليست منقطعه عن
تاريخ النكبه انها شاهد على استمرارها في
جميع الجغرافيا الفلسطينيه في الضفه
الغربيه وفي الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله
وفي القدس في غزه على نحو اخص تاخذ
الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه معنى مختلفا فهي
استهداف لاخر القلاع التي لم يخدرها وهم
السلام
تعود ذكرى النكبه بعد 75 عاما وعمليه
السلام المفض الى الدوله الفلسطينيه لا
يكاد يذكرها احد انها قضيه منسيه لا تذكر
بها الا المواجهات التي تجد المقاومه
الفلسطينيه مدفوعه اليها دفاعا عن النفس
وعن القدس ومقدساتها وقد اصطنع العالم
بكثير من المكر مصطلحي التهدئه والتصعيد
لاداره الصراع الفلسطينيه الاسرائيلي وذلك
بافراغه من محتواه السياسي ومن قضيته
الاساسيه وهي الصراع على الارض بين
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وبين الشعب الفلسطيني
المطالب بحقوقه المدافع عنها ومصطلح
التهدئه يعني اي يكف الطرفان الاسرائيلي
والفلسطيني عن المواجهه عن العنف
ويخلد الى الهدوء الهدوء الذي لا تبدد
سكينته طلقه ماء او مظاهره ما ضد تدريس
المسجد الاقصى او مص ارض او هدم منزل
التهدئه تعني تابيد الوضع على ما هو عليه
تابيد الاحتلال اما التصعيد فهو خروج على
الوضع الراهن تجبه مصارعه لاحتوائه
واحتوائه يعني اسكات المقاومه بين يدي
ذكرى النكبه القديمه الجديده لا حديث عن
عمليه السلام لا حديث عن دعوه الاطراف
للجلوس الى طاوله التفاوض فالحديث عن
الشرعيه الدوليه وعن حق الشعوب في تحرير
ارضها وحقها في المقاومه لا يسعفه السياق
هنا ففلسطين ليست اوكرانيا التي يمجد
الغرب شجاعتها في حرب الغاصبين ارضها
الاعتداء الاخير على غزه متزامنا مع
ذكريات النكبه الاولى يدعو الفلسطيني سجين
مصطلحي تهدئه والتصعيد وهما مصطلحان
يكرسان الاحتلال كما لا يفعل اي مصطلح اخر
انهما مصطلحان يكرسان النكبه الفلسطي ليس
باعتبارها ماساه فلسطينيه وقعت في الماضي
بل يحرسان صيرورتها
الماساويه اليوم وغدا وسيبقى يان كذلك حتى
ترد القضيه الى اصلها صراع بين قوه
اسرائيليه معتديه غاصبه للارض وبين شعب
يقاتل من اجل حقوقه خارج مصطلحي التهدئه
والتصعيد اللذين يؤننان المعتديه ويسكتان
الضحيه وهذه مقاربه في راي كثير من
الفلسطينيين اقل ما تفعله انها تؤبد
الاحتلال
تؤبد النكبه
[موسيقى]
قالت هيئه الدفاع عن راشد الغنوشي رئيس
حركه النهضه ان المحكمه التونسيه المحكمه
الابتدائيه في تونس قضت بسجن الغنوشي مده
عام واحد مع غرامه ماليه فيما عرف بملف
الطواغيت وهي الدعوه التي تقدم بها احد
عناصر النقابات الامنيه متهما الغنوشي
بانه وصف الامنيين بالطواغيت اثناء تابينه
احد قيادات حركه النهضه اثر وفاته وتجدر
الاشاره الى ان راشد الغنوشي محال على ذمه
هذه القضيه بحاله سراح وقد وجهت اليه تهم
تتعلق بتمجيد الارهاب واكد المحامون ان
الغنوشي المسجون منذ حوالي شهر لم يحضر
جلسه الحكم وقد كان قرر ان يقاطع كل جلسات
التحقيق
من تونس معنا مدير مكتب الجزيره لطفي حجي
لطفي ما هي ردود الفعل
ردود الفعل صدرت الان منذ قليل البيان
لجبهه الخلاص الوطني يعتبر انه هناك ليس
هناك اي
قرينه من شانها ان تجرم ما ارتكبه او ما
صرح به الغنوشي وانه يحال لمجرد التصريحات
قالها منذ سنتين في تابين احد قيادات
النهضه وانه عندما مثل امام حاكم التحقيق
في هذه القضيه في وقت سابق فسر لهما معنى
الطاغوت كما وردت في القران في اكثر من
معنى حتى ان المحامين في تلك الجلسه قال
ان هذا ليس بتحقيق امني وانه كانه ندوه
فكريه لانه فسر هذا المضمون من ناحيه
الفكريه والتاريخيه الى غير ذلك جبهه
الخلاص اعتبرت ان هذا استهداف للمعارضين
من اجل التصريحات وان هذا الاستهداف لم
منه سياسيين والاعلاميين
والمدونين
وابرزت كيف ان عدد المعتقلين في القضايا
التي تتعلقوا بالتصريحات وبالراي ارتفع في
الاسابيع الاخيره بالنسبه لهذه القضيه
عثمان هي تعتبر واحده من القضايا العديده
التي يلاحق فيها راشد
الغنوشي ابرزها ربما هي ما يعرف بملف
التسفير الى بؤر التوتر هناك قيادي نائب
رئيس الحركه في هذه القضيه هناك القضيه هو
المسجون الان
بمقتضاها ويتعلق بتصريحات التي القاها في
ندوه نظمتها جبهه الخلاصه الوطني في نهايه
رمضان الماضي هناك قضيه تتعلق بما يعرف في
تونس بشركه انستالي وشركه المختصه في
صناعه المحتوى وتتهمها
السلطات بانها تبيض الاموال لصالح النهضه
كل هذه القضايا وغيرها رفض الغنوشي ان
يحضر جلسات التحقيق هو في السجن رفض
الخروج وكتب الاسبوع الماضي
اعتراف او
توقيع على بيان اخرجه المحامون من السجن
قال انني انا راشد الغنوشي ارفضوا الحضور
في جلسات تحقيق في محكمه لا تتوفر فيها
شروط العداله
ومجعوله
لتركيز حكم فردي استبداادي هكذا قال وبسبب
هذا هو يرفض الحضور في القضايا ما يعتبرها
مسيسه ويعتبرها استهداف للخصوم السياسيين
وهو نفس
الموقف الذي عبرت عنه جبهه الخلاص الوطني
في البيان وعبرت عنه سابقا شكرا شكرا
جزيلا لك من تونس مدير مكتب الجزيره لطفي
حجي
[موسيقى]
اعلنت القوات الاوكرانيه انها حققت
انتصارات في مدينه باخموت وسيطرت على عشره
مواقع روسيه في ضواحيها
قائد ميليشيا فنفهم نشرته
بشان اتصالاته مع المخابرات الاوكرانيه
وحصل
الرئيسكي خلال زيارته لندن على وعود
بمساعدات عسكريه جديده
مدينه بخموت او ما تبقى منها اكثر من تسعه
اشهر من المعارك دون حسم استعصت المدينه
على الروس الذين لم يتمكنوا من اكماد
السيطره عليها رغم مجهود عسكري مرهق
الان تقول القوات الاوكرانيه انها تحقق
اولا انتصاراتها في عمليه الدفاع عن بخموت
قائد القوات الارضيه الاوكرانيه اكد ان
قواته سيطرت على اكثر من عشره مواقع روسيه
في ضواحي بخموت اما روسيا فقد اعلنت ان
اثنين من قادتها العسكريين قتل في معارك
قرب المدينه تبعد بخمه
578 كيلومترا عن العاصمه كييف هي مدينه
صغيره لكنها تحولت الى رمز للصمود بالنسبه
للاوكرانيين ولذلك فاي انتصار فيها قبيل
الهجوم المضاد المتوقع سيعطي دفعه معنويه
كبيره للاوكرانيين
اما بالنسبه
للروسين قائد ميليشيا باجنر الذي يحارب
رجاله في الصفوف الاماميه في بحموت سبب
كثيرا من الحرج للكرملين بتصريحاته انتقد
بريكوجين مرارا وزير الدفاع وقائد الاركان
الروسيين واتهمهما بتمد عدم مد قواته
بالذخائر الان تنشر صحيفه واشنطن بوست ان
بريكوجين اجرى اتصالات مع المخابرات
الاوكرانيه وانه عرض عليها معلومات عن
مواقع الجيش الروسي مقابل انسحابي قوات
اوكرانيه من مواقع قرب بخموت نافا ما
نشرته الواشنطن بوست وقال انه مضحك واتهم
النخبه التي قال انها تسكن في احد الاحياء
الراقيه بموسكو بالوقوف وراء هذه
المعلومات يفضل بريكوجين توجيه سهام نقده
للنخب في موسكو على توجيهها للغرب الذي
يزود اوكرانيا بالعتاد الذي يستخدم غيرها
في لندن حيث استقبله رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني حسن الرئيس الاوكراني على
مساعدات بريطانيه جديده ضمنها مئات
الصواريخ الدفاعيه بالاضافه الى طائرات
مسيره يصل مداها الى اكثر من 200 كيلومتر
قبل لندننسكي روما وبرلين وباريس وحصل على
وعود بمساعدات المانيه بثلاثه مليارات
دولار ومساعدات عسكريه فرنسيه وقال ان
اخبارا عن تزويد بلاده بطائره غربيه
متطوره قريبه تبدو هذه الجوله كجزء من
الاستعداد للهجوم الاوكراني المضاد الذي
سيحتاج كثيرا من العتاد
ينضم الينا من كييف يوريساك مستشار وزير
الدفاع الاوكرانيه سيدي ريساك كيف يمكن ان
تصف لنا الوضع العسكري الان في هذه الحرب
بين الطرفين
مساء الخير لكم بالنسبه الى الوضع العسكري
في الميدان فهو يستمر بان يكون في غايه
الصعوبه وخصوصا في محيط مدن مثل مارينكا
ومثل بخموت نحن نتحدث في مناطق شرق
اوكرانيا في منطقه
ان العدو قد سوى المدن بالارض لم يتبقى اي
شيء تقريبا ولكن في الوقت نفسه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه حققت نجاحات وتمكنت من
الاستيلاء على مواقع متعدده في محيط مدينه
بخموت من خلال هذه الهجمات المضاده نحن
نتحدث عن منطقه
مساحتها حوالي كيلو مترين مربعين قد تبدو
المسافه او المساحه محدوده ولكن يجب ان
نتذكر ان مدينه بخموت هي المدينه التي
يحاول الجيش الروسي ان يستولي ويسيطر
عليها منذ عشره اشهر تقريبا لذلك نحن نجهز
للعمليه المضاده ولكن في الوقت نفسه هناك
بعض النجاحات التي حققناها في مدن من مثل
بخموت متى ستكون هذه العمليه الاوكرانيه
المضاده التي طال الحديث عنها
في البدايه بنسبه الى التاريخ بالتحديد
التاريخ المحدد لا يمكننا ان نشير اليه
لان العمليه المضاده ليست عمليه تبدا
بنقطه محدده في الزمان نحن نتحدث عن سلسله
من العمليات العسكريه التي فيها تعقيدات
متعدده
وهناك عمليات متعدده يمكن ان نتحدث عنها
لذلك من غير الممكن ان نحدد تاريخا محددا
لبدايه العمليه الاوكرانيه المضاده التي
سوف تقوم بها القوات الاوكرانيه ولكنه
يمكننا ان نتحدث عن تجهيزات في الجانب
الاوكراني لهذه العمليه على اي حال يمكننا
ان نقول ان هذه
العمليه سوف تسمح للقوات الاوكرانيه تحرير
الاراضي الاوكرانيه ونحن بدانا بالتجهيزات
النهائيه الرئيس جوله الان وحصل على وعود
من بريطانيا والمانيا وفرنسا للحصول على
اسلحه جديده لماذا يقول انه بحاجه الى وقت
اكثر وهو في الماضي يعني في فتره كان يقول
انه مستعجل ولن ينتظر حتى ان تاتي
الطائرات البريطانيه في ذلك الوقت ولكن
الان لماذا يقول انه بحاجه الى وقت اكثر
عندما يتخذ القرار بالنسبه الى العمليه
المضاده ياخذ هذا القرار الاوجه المتعدده
الظروف الجويه المعدات العسكريه الاسلحه
الميدانيه وضع القوات الميدانيه باضافه
الى وضع الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه ما
قال ما تحدث عنه الرئيس الاوكراني هو اننا
بحاجه الى المزيد من الوقت للاستعداد لهذه
العمليه الواسعه النطاق ما عناه هو اننا
نقدر القيمه البشريه والارواح البشريه
ونحن لا نرسل الرجال لكي يقتلوا في
الميدان من دون ان نابهه بشان ارواحهم نحن
نقدر قيمه الانسان الاوكراني ولذلك
اود ان نتاكد من ان الجيش الاوكراني لديه
ما يكفي من جاهزيه واستعداد ومعدات واعداد
وعتيد من اجل تقليص الخسائر في الارواح في
جانب الجيش الاوكراني عندما يتم الانتهاء
من هذه الاعدادات والتجهيزات سوف تبدا
العمليه المضاده ولقد ذكر الرئيس في خلال
زيارته التي اشرتم اليها الى البلدان
الاوروبيه وذكر امام الحلفاء واستمع من
الحلفاء الى انهم سوف يستمرون بدعم
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه الضروريه لكي ان تحقق
اوكرانيا النصر شكرا جزيلا لك مستشار وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني من كييف والى موسكو نرحب
بالعقيد فيكتور
محرر الشؤون العسكريه في وكاله تاسع
الروسيه اهلا وسهلا بك عشره اشهر تتحدث
روسيا عن محاوله للسيطره على بخمه ولم
تتمكن من فعل ذلك حتى هذه اللحظه لماذا
الامر مستعصم الى هذه الدرجه
رشيد روسيا لم تقل انها
طوالي عشر اشهر
سيطر على بخمه لقد سيطرنا فعلا على باقي
متبقيه بعض الاحياء لذلك لدينا المزيد من
الوقت ونحن لسنا في عجل
عدا عن ذلك عندما يتحدث الممثل من كيف
انهم يحافظون على ارواح الجنود
الاوكرانيين هذا ليس حقيقي
تثبت انهم خسروا ما يزيد عن 30 الف من
ارواح جنودهم حتى يسيطروا على المدينه
التي يقولون عنها انها ليست مهمه انهم لا
يحافظون على ارواح جنودهم للاسف لو كانوا
يفعلون هذا لا قاموا بتحرير والاقامه
بالخروج من هذا من هذه المدينه طيب يعني
ما زالت هناك بعض الاحياء كما تقول هذا
يعني انه ليست هناك سيطره كامله على على
ولكن سؤالي لك الان اوكرانيا تتزود بمزيد
من الاسلحه المتطوره من دول اوروبيه
كيف تتوقع ان ذلك سوف يؤثر على المشهد
عسكريا
الواقع هم لا يحصلوا على اسلحه متطوره
الاسلحه كلها قديمه على سبيل المثال
دبابات
واحد هذا هذه اسلحه من عام
والكثير من المعدات التي ترسلها الدول
الغربيه لاوكرانيا ترسلها للتخلص منها
وهذا ما سوف تقوم به القوات الاوكرانيه
والروسيه عفوا والا لانفقوا الاموال على
التخلص من هذه المعدات القديمه ولكن روسيا
تساعدهم في هذا في التخلص من هذه الاسلحه
وسوف تحصل اوكرانيا على المال مقابل
التخلص من المعدات القديمه الاوروبيه لذلك
المعدات لا تحل ولا تسهل الاوضاع العسكريه
ما يحل الاوضاع العسكريه هي المهارات
العسكريه ليس لدى اوكرانيا
لذلك عندما يتحدثون عن الهجمات
المعاكسه هم يتحدثون عن هذا وهم يعلمون
انهم ليس لديهم دبابات كافيه او مدافع او
هليكوبترات هجوميه او الطائرات وانظمتهم
الدفاعيه الجويه ضعيفه جدا لذلك الهجمات
العكسيه للقوات الاوكرانيه سوف تكون
عمليات انتحاريه ولهذا هم يقومون بتاجيلها
شكرا شكرا جزيلا من موسكو العقيد فيكتور
كان محرر الشؤون العسكريه في وكاله تاس
الروسيه
قال البيت الابيض انه سيعلن خلال الايام
المقبله عن عقوبات جديده ضد المتورطين في
تزويد روسيا باسلحه من ايران
واضاف منسق والاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي ان
ايران قدمت لروسيا اكثر من 400 طائره
مسيره وقذائف مدفعيه لاستخدامها في
اوكرانيا
كما قال كيربي ان واشنطن ترى مؤشرات على
توسع الشراكه العسكريه بين ايران وروسيا
وان ايران تسعى للحصول على مروحيات هجوميه
وردارات من روسيا بمليارات الدولارات
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان طائره
مقاتله من ترانسوخوي 27 اعترضت طائرتين
احداهما فرنسيه والاخرى الالمانيه فوق بحر
البلطيق ومنعتهما من اختراق المجال الجوي
الروسي
الى باكستان حيث توعد الجيش بتقديم من
وصفهم بالمتورطين في جرائم شنيع ضد
المنشات العسكريه والافراد الى المحاكمه
على خلفيه اعمال الشغب التي اندلعت عقب
اعتقال رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان في
التاسع من الشهر الجاري وقال الجيش في
بيان له بعد اجتماع لقيادته اليوم انه لن
يمارس ضبط النفس ضد من سماهم الجنات
والمفسدين
والمخالفين تحت اي ظرف من الظروف
كما استنكر الجيش ما وصفها بالحرب
الدعائيه المدعومه من الخارج والميسره
داخليا والتي اطلقت ضد قياده الجيش كما
قال
وما تزال الملاحقات القضائيه التي يواجهها
عمران خان واعتقاله الاسبوع الماضي قبل
الافراج عنه يثير المزيد من ردود الفعل
ومثل خان مجددا امام محكمه لاهور العليا
حيث يواجه اتهامات للمسؤوليه عن اعمال عنف
ومواجهات حدثت عقب اعتقالهم في هذه
الاثناء نظم حزبان من الائتلاف الحاكم
مظاهره امام المحكمه العليا في العاصمه
الباكستانيه اسلام ابادر احتجاجا على ما
وصفوه بالمعامله القضائيه التفضيليه
لعمران خان
وطالب المتظاهرون رئيس القضاه في البلاد
بالاستقاله
راس الساعه وهذا تذكير بابرز مواضيع
الحصاد هذه الليله
بعد عدم تخطي اي من المرشحين عتبه الخمسين
في المئه من الاصوات تركيا تتجه الى جوله
ثانيه للانتخابات الرئاسيه لاول مره في
تاريخ الجمهوريه وتحالف حزب العداله
والتنميه يحافظ على اغلبيته في البرلمان
المواجهات في السودان تدخل شهرها الثاني
اشتباكات متفرقه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع في مناطق جنوب الخرطوم وام درمان
ومرحله ثانيه من المفاوضات بين طرفي
الاقتتال بحضور ممثلين للوساطه الامريكيه
السعوديه ومع اتساع المواجهات في غرب
دارفور حاكم الاقليم يقول ان المكونات
الرسميه هناك تناى بنفسها عن القتال
كيف تعلن تحقيق ما اعتبرته اول نجاحا في
هجومها في محيط باخموت وروسيا تقول انها
تتقدم في المدينه
وبعد جوله اوروبيه زيلينسكي يحصل على مزيد
من الاسلحه من بريطانيا تتضمن طائرات
مسيره هجوميه بعيده المدى البيت الابيض
يقول ان ايران وروسيا توسعان تعاونهم
العسكريه غير المسبوق وكيف تستقبل
الثلاثاء مفردا صينيا لبحث فرص التسويه
بعد اسبوع من الاضطرابات في باكستان
تحذيرات شديده اللهجه من الجيش عشيه
اجتماع للقيادات الامنيه والسياسيه ببحث
الاوضاع في البلاد سنحاكم الضلعين في
تخريب منشات عسكريه ولن نمارس ضبط النفس
واحتجاجات على وقع مثور عمران خان امام
القضاء مجددا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
حكم بالسجن على رئيس حركه النهضه راشد
الغنوشي على خلفيه تصريح حركه النهضه تدين
وجبهه الخلاص تقول ان السلطه تؤول
تصريحاته لغياب اي ادله تضيق
[موسيقى]
نبدا من تركيا التي تخوض للمره الاولى في
تاريخها جوله ثانيه للانتخابات الرئاسيه
في اعقاب دوره اولى شهدت منافسه محتدمه
بين الرئيس للرجب طيب اردوغان الذي حصل
على نسبه
49.50%
ومنافسه الرئيسي كمال كالجدار اوغلو الذي
حقق 45%
انتهى فرز الاصوات في الانتخابات التركيه
التي وصفت بالمصريه دون ان تحدد مصير
البلاد
[موسيقى]
قالت هذه الصناديق كلمتها فمنح التحالف
الجمهور الذي يقوده حزب العداله والتنميه
الحاكم فوزا مريحا في البرلمان لكنها لم
تحسم فوز زعيم الحزب الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
بالرغم من تقدمه بفارق كبير عن منافسه
مرشح المعارضه كما الكليج دارول
وفقا للقانون الانتخابي لم يفز اي من
المرشحين في الانتخابات الرئاسيه وعليه
قررنا عقد جوله ثانيه يوم الثامن والعشرين
من مايو الجاري الصحف المقربه من الحكومه
رات ان اراده الشعب تجلد في هذه النتائج
عندما منحت اردوغان اصواتا بفارق وصل الى
نحو مليونين ونصف مليون صوت عن منافسه
بينما رات صحف المعارضه ان الرجل خسر هذه
الانتخابات بل وات الحكومه بمحاوله
التلاعب في النتائج لكن يبقى ان عوامل عده
حرمت اردوغان الفوز من الجوله الاولى في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه وافقدته اسطنبول
والعاصمه انقره اكبر المدن التركيه وهو
الذي لطالما حصل على النسبه الاكبر من
اصوات المدينتين
الاقتصاد والزلزال في تركيا اضرار الحكومه
بشكل كبير لكن جهودها الكبير في دعم
المتضررين من الزلزال اقنعتهم بالتصويت
بشكل كبير لتحالف الجمهور اما الغلاء
والتضخم وخصوصا في المدن الكبرى فجعلك
كثيرا من الناخبين وخصوصا الشباب يفضلون
البديل
اكثر من خمسه في المئه حصل عليها المرشح
القومي سنان اوران في هذه الانتخابات لا
شك انها ستلعب الدوره الحاسمه في تحديد
نتيجه الجوله الثانيه الامر الذي يرى فيه
كثير من المراقبين ان مزيجا من الناخبين
القوميين ومن العلمانيين الغاضبين من
انسحاب مرشحهم محرم انجاح بشكل مفاجئ قبل
عده ايام من الانتخابات سيكون رمانه
القبان في هذه الجوله يقول حزب العداله
والتنميه انه حقق انتصاره السادسه عشر على
التوالي في تاريخه لكنه يبدو انتصارا
منقوصا هذه المره سيقود الحزب الى مواجهه
جديده محتدمه ستتداخل فيها عوامل خارجيه
وداخليه عده قبل ان يحسم الاسم الذي سيقود
البلاد خلال السنوات الخمس المقبله امرنا
في الجزيره اسطنبول
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان اكد ان
كوادر ولجان حزبه سيواصلون العمل بلا توقف
لضمان الفوز في جوله الاعاده جاء ذلك في
تغريده نشرها عقب اجتماعه باعضاء اللجنه
المركزيه لحزب العداله والتنميه في انقره
وشكر اردوغان الشعب التركي او المشاركين
في الانتخابات الذين بلغ عددهم 56 مليونا
على ما اسماه المشاركه الفاعله والقويه في
الانتخابات ووعد الرئيس التركي جمهوره
الانتخابي انهم سيخرجون منتصرين ليله
الثامن والعشرين من مايو ايار الجاري في
اشاره لتاريخ جوله الاعاده
في المقابل قال المرشح الرئاسي عن تحالف
الشعب كمال في فيديو قصير نشره على صفحته
على موقع تويتر انه جاهز للكفاح مع انصاره
حتى النهايه حسب تعبيره
انا هنا انا هنا وانتم معي ايضا هنا اقسم
انني ساكافح حتى النهايه
من انقره معنا رفعه جاه للمحلل السياسي في
مركز سيتا للابحاث اهلا وسهلا بك سيد رفعت
الجميع اذا ينتظر الجوله الثانيه هل
النتيجه
محسومه بالفعل هل هذا توقع مبالغ فيه في
ان يقول البعض ان النتيجه محسومه للرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان في الجوله الثانيه
في الحقيقه في البدايه ان الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان لديه الافضليه وذلك بناء
على نتيجه الاصوات بعد فرز الاصوات
بايات هذه الجوله
ونتحدث عن تقدم حققه السيد رجب طيب
اردوغان بالمقارنه مع الاصوات التي حصل
عليها المنافس اوغلو باضافه الى حصوله على
49.5
وبالتالي اقترب كثيرا من تحقيق النصري في
الجوله الاولى وهذا يؤدي الى وقع نفسي وفي
الوقت نفسه نحن نعرف ان هناك اعتقاد واسع
النطاق في المجتمع التركي يقول انه اذا ما
انتقلت نتيجه الانتخابات الى الجوله
الثانيه لكي تحدد هذا سوف يؤدي الى رفع
حظوظ الرئيس اردوغان وذلك بالعوده الى
العامل الاساسي في المجتمع التركي هو
الزعيم كبير ولديه كاريزما كبيره في
المجتمع التركي وباوساط الشرائح المختلفه
وبالتالي ان السيد اردوغان يعرف كيف يخاطب
الشعب ويحشد الدعم افضل من
السيد
في هذا المجال وايضا يمكننا ان نشير الى
المفاجاه التي اعتبر عدد كبير من الناس
انها مفاجاه الا وهي تحقيق السيد اوغان
نسبه الخمسه بالمئه اذا هذا امر تجدر
الاشاره اليه بالنسبه
الى هذه الانتخابات وحتى مع هذه النتيجه
نحن نعرف ان هناك قرار تاخر بنسبه الى دعم
السيد اوغان لهذه الجهه او الاخرى لان
السيد اوغان ليس لديه قاعده صلبه من
الداعمين الشخصيين له هو من وجهه نظري عدد
كبير من الداعمين
للسيد اوغان صوتوا ليس دعما له بل
التصويتا ضد جهه اخرى وهناك نريد ان نفهم
الان نعم نريد ان نفهم ما يمكن ان يحدث في
الجوله الثانيه هل يستطيع السيد
مزيد من الاصوات هل يستطيع السيد رجب طيب
اردوغان الرئيس التركي ان يكسب اصوات بعض
من الذين لم يصوتوا
له وبالتالي ان كان لا يريدان ذلك فهل هما
مستعدان لتقديم تنازلات وماذا يمكن ان
تكون هذه التنازلات
[موسيقى]
سبق واسلفت ان الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
لديه شعبيه كبيره في اوساط المجتمع التركي
ولديه كاريزما وهو زعيم لديه دعم في
المجتمع التركي لذلك حظوظه كبيره بالنسبه
الى الجوله الثانيه بالنسبه الى المعطيات
التي لدينا الان هناك اولويات سياسيه ممكن
الحديث عنها وهي الاولويات الاساسيه في
تركيا وهي ليست من ضمن اولويات السيد سنان
اوغان وبالتالي من غير المرجح ان يدعم
السيد اوغان ايا من هذين المرشحين
الرئيسيين بالاضافه الى ذلك نحن نعرف انه
في الفتره التي سبقت الجوله الاولى من
الانتخابات كان هناك توقعات منتشره بان
المعارضه التركيه سوف تحصد دعما عارما
وسوف تكسب في هذه الانتخابات وان السيد
سوف يكسب هذه الانتخابات وينتصر على السيد
اردوغان ولكن هنا نعود الى العامل النفسي
الذي اشرت اليه حيث ان هذه المعنويات
تراجعت في اوساط المعارضه بعدما كانت او
اتت نتيجه الجوله الاولى اقل من التوقعات
لذلك وبناء على هذه العوامل ارى ان حظوظ
السيد اردوغان سوف تكون اكبر في الجوله
الثانيه بالمقارنه مع حدود من انقره رفعه
انجيل المحلل السياسي في مركز سته للابحاث
شكرا لك
مع مرور شهر على الاشتباكات المسلحه في
السودان بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
يتواصل القتال في العاصمه الخرطوم تحديدا
وسط اتهامات متبادله بقصف احياء مدنيه كما
شهدت مدينه الجنينه الغربيه دارفور
اشتباكات بين الدعم السريع ومجموعات مسلحه
سقط على اثرها نحو 200 قتيل خلال يومين
المشهد ذاته في السودان تتكرس مشاهد
القتال بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
للشهر الثاني على التوالي طبق الخرطوم
عنوان هذا القتال ينحصر اطلاق النار في
مركز العاصمه تقريبا حيث المقر السياديه
للبلاد يقصف الجيش مواقع للدعم في العاصمه
يقول انه تعامل مع امدادات اللوجستيه
كبيره من الاسلحه والذخائر والوقود يرد
الدعم السريع باتهام الجيش بقصف مناطق
ماهوله بالمدنيين منها مستشفى شرق النيل
بالعاصمه هكذا يريد كل طرف ان يثبت اقدامه
في العاصمه ساعيا نحو قلب موازين السيطره
العسكريه مع دخول المعارك شهره الثاني
يصدر رئيس مجلس السياده قائد الجيش قرارات
جديده يعفي البرهان وزير الداخليه المكلف
ومدير عام الشرطه وينهي خدمه سفيرين
بوزاره الخارجيه دون توضيح الاسباب يحيل
الى التقاعد ضباط في الجيش كانوا منتدبين
لدى قوات السريع قبل اندلاع الازمه من بين
هؤلاء رئيس وفد الدعم السريع في محادثات
جده يذهب البرهان ابعد من ذلك يضيق الخناق
ماديا على حمتي وقواته بتجميد حسابات
الدعم في البنوك داخل وخارج البلاد بعد ان
كان قد اقال محافظا للبنك المركزي كل ذلك
والاعين نحو جده هناك بدات المرحله
الثانيه من المحادثات بين طرفي القتال
كانت المرحله الاولى قد بدات بعد ثلاثه
اسابيع من اندلاع الازمه اتفق المتقاتلون
فيها على اعلان مبادئ لحمايه المدنيين
وتجنب وقوعهم في دائره الخطر في الجوله
الثانيه الحاليه يحضر ممثلون عن الوساطه
الامريكيه السعوديه يمكن ان يتم الاتفاق
على وقف دائم لاطلاق النار تتم مراقبته
عبر الاقمار الاصطناعيه من الدول الراعيه
للمباحثات بالاضافه الامكانيات وجود
مراقبين على الارض من الاتحاد الافريقي كل
هذه التفاصيل موافقه مصدر سوداني مطلع صرح
بها للجزيره قبل جلسات جده وبعدها اتفق
الطرفان على عده هدن لكنها لم تفضي الى
توقف القتال او رسم ملامح حل للازمه
احاديث القتال والسيطره على الميدان
توازيها احاديث المفاوضات وتفاصيل الهدى
ووقف اطلاق النار لا لهم من كل ذلك وفق
السودانيين والوضع الانساني
قرابه 250 انسانا قتلوا واصيب اكثر من
ثلاثه الاف في الخرطوم وحدها خلال شهر من
المعارك لكن خلال يومين فقط قتل اكثر من
280 في اشتباكات بولايه دارفور غربيه
البلاد اذ تفيد نقابه الاطباء السودانيه
بانهيار كامل للنظام الصحي في مدينه
الجنينه عاصمه ولايه غرب دارفور
هكذا يبقى المشهد على حاله في السودان 30
يوما من القتال لم توقفها المنشدات
الدوليه ولا المفاوضات الجاريه تصبح الان
واحدا وثلاثين يوما ولا يبدو ان العد
سيتوقف هنا
معنا في الاستوديو ضياء الدين بلال الكاتب
الصحفي والمحلل السياسي السوداني اهلا
وسهلا استاذ ضياء يعني القتال مستمر
والمحادثات مستمره
وايضا كانت هناك القرارات من رئيس مجلس
السياده باحاله البعض الى المعاش باقاله
البعض هذا كله يتم اثناء استمرار محادثات
كيف يمكن ان نفهم ذلك من الطبيعه ان تتحرك
العمليات العسكريه دون ان تكون هنالك
اختبار
للتفاوض وهذا واضح من خلال عدم الالتزام
بالهدنه في كل المرات التي ولدت فيها
الهدنه فهنالك معطيات ميدانيه هي التي
تحدد خيارات الاطراف في التعامل العسكري
اكثر من كون ان هنالك محددات ملزمه من قبل
التفاوض لا اعتقد ان التفاوض الى الان
اصبح له التاثير الاكبر على مجريات
الاوضاع بس مع التوقيع على اعلان المبادئ
كثيرون توقعوا انه لا يكون الامر مثل
الهدى السابقه ان يكون هناك التزام ان
يكون هناك بعض التهدئه نعم ليس هنالك
اليات طابطه ومراقبه لما يحدث من اطلق من
من الذي يخترق هذه الهدنه هذا امر جدلي
وكل ط يتهم الاخر فبالتالي اي توقع لان
تكون هنالك متغيرات ميدانيه كبيره متعلقه
بالتهدئه في ظل الاوضاع القائمه الان خاصه
الاوضاع العسكريه التي تجعل من الدعم
السريع مسيطر على بعض الاماكن الحساسه
والحيويه ولا يستطيع الجيش ان يتغاضى عن
هذا الامر فبالتالي هو يتعامل مع هذا
الامر كجزء من تعامله مع التفاوض باعتبار
انه يريد ان يخلى
بالقوه العسكريه الدعم السريع من هذه
المناطق واذا لم ينجح في ذلك ان يضغط على
الدعم السريع حتى يستجيب على موائد
التفاوض بان ينسحب من هذه المناطق
الاستراتيجيه لان نحتقد ان الجيش انجز
كثير من المهام العسكريه التي كانت متعلقه
باضعاف الدعم السريعي الى اقصى درجه ممكنه
حتى يصبح عنصر ضعيف في المعادله القادمه
اذا اذا اذا توفرت ظروف لتفاوض اوسع
المفروض انه في تفاوض اوسع الان هناك
الجوله الثانيه من الباحثات ما تعتقد فرص
التوصل لنتائج في هذه الجوله مع وجود
بصراحه لهجه حاده من الطرفين سمعنا تسجيل
لقائد الدعم السريع مثلا
الاخير اللهجه كانت حاده جدا تجاه البرهان
هي هي تبدو ان هنالك دوافع شخصيه
ومحددات ومحركات ومحفات شخصيه متعلقه
بالفريق مهاجمه البرهان هذا
ظهر وهذا ظهر في الفتره الاخيره البرهان
الى حد كبير كان يحاول ان يتوازن في هذا
لكن هناك لهجه
من الجيش نعم هنالك بعض الاطراف خاصه
للفريق الكباشي
والفريق العطا كانت لهجتهم حاده اتجاه
اتجاه الى ان يبدو ان المساجد العام
المزاج العام
المحيط بهذه العمليات العسكريه اتجاه هذه
هذه اللغه الحاده خاصه وان هنالك ممارسات
مسد عصب الحياه في السودان متعلقه بالتجاء
الدعم السريعي الى المقر الى المساكن
المواطنين والى المقر المتعلقه
بالمستشفيات لم يتغير هذا بعد توقيع على
اعلان مبادئ لانه كان يستهدف بالاساس هذه
الامور من النواحي الانسانيه والمدنيه
الاعلان المبادئ هو التعبير عن النوايا
واقرار لما هو مقر اصلا وتاكيد للمؤكد ليس
ليس فيه ما يضاف ليس به ما يتوقف الحرب
كان هناك التزام من الطرفين
بمراعاه الجوانب المدنيه والانسانيه خاصه
فيما يخص المستشفيات والقطاع الصحي على
على سبيل المثال هذا لم يتم لم يتغير على
الارض خطه واتفاق واضحه على خارطه الطريق
تحدد كيفيه انسحاب القوات
القوات الدعم السريع من هذه الاماكن لا
اعتقد ان هنالك استجابه ستحدث طالما ان
الدعم السريع يسيطر على هذه ويستقل
المستشفيات مثل المستشفي شرق النيل الذي
تحول لسكنه عسكريه من قبل الدعم السريع
فما كان من الجيش الا ان يتعامل مع هذا
الواقع باعتباره يمثل تحديد عسكري بان
يتعرف الجيش ايضا بقصف عشوائي واستهداف
المدنيين نعم هو الاتهام اتهام خاصه فيما
يتعلق بالمستشفيات ما الذي يجعل جيش اي
دوله يهاجم المستشفيات ليس هنالك
معطيات موضوعيه تقول بان هنالك ما يبرر
الهجوم على المستويات ما لم ان تستقل هذه
المستشفيات والاماكن الضروريه في اعمال
عسكريه مضاده للجيش شكرا جزيلا في وهو ما
لم يقله الجيش ولم يحدث يعني حتى نكون
واضحين فيما يخص استخدام
المستشفيات في عمل عسكري وبالتالي اضطر
الجيش هذا الذكر ذلك اكثر من مره ولذلك
استهدف مستشفيات لذلك استهدف وجود لا
يستخدم المستشفيات ولكن يستهدف وجود الدعم
السريع في هذه الموسيقى شكرا جزيلا ضياء
الدين بلال الكاتب الصحفي والمحلل السياسي
السوداني
اطلقت الحداد وتوقفت الحركه مده 75 ثانيه
في مختلف المدن الفلسطينيه ايذانا ببدء
فعاليات احياء الذكرى الخامسه والسبعين
للنكبه وشارك الاف الفلسطينيين في مسيره
مركزيه في مدينه رام الله رافعين الاعلام
الفلسطينيه واسماء اكثر من 500 قريه
دمرتها القوات الاسرائيليه عام 1948
[موسيقى]
تعود ذكر النكبه الفلسطينيه ولا تزالوا
سيره الصراع مع الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هي هي
فذكرى النكبه تاتي والضحايا في غزه لما
تجف دمائهم بعده من اخر اعتداء اسرائيلي
على القطاع وهو ما يجعل النكبه صيروره في
الماساه الفلسطينيه الفلسطينيه اكثر منها
ذكرى ومع تراجع الحديث عن السلام وعن
الدوله الفلسطينيه لم يبقى من مقاربه
للتعاطي مع صراع غير المتكافئ بين
الفلسطينيين وجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الا
مصطلحي التهدئه والتصعيد وهو تكتيك
دبلوماسي لا يقول شيئا في المحصله
النهائيه غير ابقاء الوضع على ما هو عليه
انه اصطلاح مؤبد للاحتلال مصادر لحق
المقاومه في ان تقول له انه اصطلاح مؤبد
للنكبه
تقرير فوزي بشرى
[موسيقى]
وانتهى مشهد اخر من القتل ومن الدمار ومن
التضحيات مشهد من سيره الحرب على قطاع غزه
من سيره النكبه التي كانت ولم تزل هل
تختلف مشاهد القصف بين حرب وحرب الا
بمقدار الاختلاف بين قتل وقتل
الا تتشابه مواكب الشهداء بين امس واليوم
الشهداء الذين يمنحون للموت معنا الحياه
وللقضيه الفلسطينيه معنى ان تبقى حيه قضيه
تقلق الضمير الانسانيه وان تعامى عنها ليس
بوصفها ذكرى لنكبه حدثت عام 48
غضت بتواطؤ دولي ان تلقي شعبا من الوجود
وان تبعث اخر
الاعتداء الاسرائيلي الاخير على غزه الذي
اغتال عددا من القاده في سرايا القدس
الجناح العسكري للجهاد الاسلامي ودمر وقتل
واصاب بنا المدنيين ما اصاب هو فصل من
تاريخ متصل على مدى 75 عاما منذ كانت
العصابات تقتل وتحرق وتستبيح البدن
والبلدات الفلسطينيه لتصنع دولتها على
حساب الفلسطيني وتصنع مشروع امنها وحياتها
على ارهاب الفلسطيني
ودفعه الى اللجوء والنزوح قصه النكبه امس
هي قصتها اليوم
ومعادله امس هي معادلتها اليوم سلام
اسرائيل وتوسعها مرتبط ارتباطا عضويا بقتل
الفلسطيني وارحابه وسجنه ودفعه الى حواف
العدم باقتلاعه من الارض
خمسه ايام غزه الاخيره ليست مقطعه عن
تاريخ النكبه انها شاهد على استمرارها في
جميع الجغرافيا الفلسطينيه في الضفه
الغربيه وفي الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله
وفي القدس في غزه على نحو اخص تاخذ
الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه معنى مختلفا فهي
استهداف لاخر القلاع التي لم يخدرها وهم
السلام
تعود ذكرى النكبه بعد 75 عاما وعمليه
السلام المفض الى الدوله الفلسطينيه لا
يكاد يذكرها احد انها قضيه منسيه لا تذكر
بها الا المواجهات التي تجد المقاومه
الفلسطينيه مدفوعه اليها دفاعا عن النفس
وعن القدس ومقدساتها وقد اصطنع العالم
بكثير من المكر مصطلحي التهدئه والتصعيد
لاداره الصرع الفلسطينيه الاسرائيلي وذلك
بافراغه من محتواه السياسي ومن قضيته
الاساسيه وهي الصراع على الارض بين
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وبين الشعب الفلسطيني
المطالب بحقوقه المدافع عنها ومصطلح
التهدئه يعني اي يكف الطرفان الاسرائيلي
والفلسطيني عن المواجهه عن العنف
ويخلداء الى الهدوء الهدوء الذي لا تبدد
سكينته طلقه ماء او مظاهره ما ضد تدريس
المسجد الاقصى او مص ارض او هدم منزل
التهدئه تعني تابيد الوضع على ما هو عليه
تابيد الاحتلال اما التصعيد فهو خروج على
الوضع الراهن تجبه مصارعه لاحتوائه
واحتوائه يعني اسكات المقاومه بين يدي
ذكرى النكبه القديمه الجديده لا حديث عن
عمليه السلام لا حديث عن دعوه الاطراف
للجلوس الى طاوله التفاوض فالحديث عن
الشرعيه الدوليه وعن حق الشعوب في تحرير
ارضها وحقها في المقاومه لا يزعفه السياق
هنا ففلسطين ليست اوكرانيا التي يمجد
الغرب شجاعتها في حرب الغاصبين ارضها
الاعتداء الاخير على غزه متزامنا مع
ذكريات النكبه الاولى يدعو الفلسطيني سجين
مصطلحي تهدئه والتصعيد وهما مصطلحان
يكرسان الاحتلال كما لا يفعل اي مصطلح اخر
انهما مصطلحان يكرسان النكبه الفلسطي ليس
باعتبارها ماساه فلسطينيه وقعت في الماضي
بل يحرسان صيرورتها
الماساويه اليوم وغدا وسيبقى يان كذلك حتى
ترد القضيه الى اصلها صراع بين قوه
اسرائيليه معتديه غاصبه للارض وبين شعب
يقاتل من اجل حقوقه خارج مصطلحي التهدئه
والتصعيد اللذين يؤننان المعتديه ويسكتان
الضحيه وهذه مقاربه في راي كثير من
الفلسطينيين اقل ما تفعله انها تؤبد
الاحتلال
تؤبد النكبه
[موسيقى]
قالت هيئه الدفاع عن راشد الغنوشي رئيس
حركه النهضه ان المحكمه الابتدائيه في
تونس قضت بسجن الغنوشي مده عام واحد مع
غرامه ماليه فيما عرف بملف الطواغيت وهي
الدعوه التي تقدم بها احد عناصر النقابات
الامنيه متهمه للغنوشي بانه وصف الامنيين
بالطواغيت اثناء تابينه احد قيادات حركه
النهضه اثر وفاته وتجدر الاشاره التي تجر
الاشاره الى ان راشد الغنوشي محال على ذمه
هذه القضيب القضيه بحاله سراح وقد وجهت
اليه تهم تتعلق بتمجيد الارهاب واكد
المحامون ان الغنوشي المسجون منذ حوالي
شهر لم يحضر جلسه الحكم وقد كان قرر ان
يقاطع كل جلسات التحقيق
من جهتها جبهه الخلاص الوطني في تونس قالت
ان الحكم الصادره بحق راشد الغنوشي رئيس
حركه النهضه يثبت ان السلطه لم تستطع
اثبات اي اعمال ماديه
مجرمه في حقه وان لا احد من المعارضين
مهما كان موقعه او انتمائه في مامن من
مصادره حريته والزج به في السجن واضافت
جبهه الخلاص الوطني في بياننا ان الحكم
على الغنوشي وايداعه اكثر من 20 شخصيه
سياسيه في السجن دون حجه او تبرير سوى كيل
التهم جزافا ولانحراف بالسلطه والقانون
واشارت الى ان سياسه القمع هي نتيجه
مباشره للانقلاب على الدستور والانفراد
بالحكم المطلق وملاذق السلطه في وجه فشلها
في معالجه الازمه الماليه والاجتماعيه
الخانقه التي تجتازها البلاد
بل قاسم حسن عضو المكتب التنفيذي لحركه
النهضه قال ان كلام رئيس حركه النهضه رئيس
راشد الغنوشي تم تاويله وانه عندما استخدم
كلمه الطواغيت كان يتحدث بشكل مطلق وعام
ولم يكن يقصد اي جهه
كل معناها ما له علاقه
بالاستبداد وبالظلم وغير ذلك
وحذر رئيس الحركه الاستاذ راشد الغنوشي
جلسه في هذا الموضوع سابقا وشرح
لقضيه التحقيق انذاك شرح له هذا المصطلح
يعني لا اجهزه الامن التونسيه ولا غيرها
ولا طرفا بعينه كان يتحدث فيه بشكل مطلق
وعام
وقال ابو القاسم حسن عضو المكتب التنفيذيه
ان الحكم الذي صدر بحق رئيس حركه النهضه
راشد الغنوشي كان مفاجئا وان محاميه
سيقدمون استئنافا
رغم انه هو في حاله ايداع في حاله ايقاف
بالسجن في
تمت لقضيه اخرى وبنعمه عليه هذا الحكم
اليوم بالسجن لمده سنه وخطيه بالف دينار
وامر الذي فجاءنا ونعتقد ان ان المحامين
سوف يرفعون
استئناف ضد هذه القضيه
[موسيقى]
الى باكستان حيث توعد الجيش بتقديم من
وصفهم بالمتورطين في جرائم شنيع ضد
المنشات العسكريه والافراد الى المحاكمه
على خلفيه اعمال الشغب التي اندلعت عقب
اعتقال رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان في
التاسع من الشهر الجاري وقال الجيش في
بيان له بعد اجتماع لقيادته اليوم انه لن
يمارس ضبط النفس ضد من سماهم الجنات
والمفسدين والمخالفين تحت اي ظرف من
الظروف كما استنكر الجيش ما وصفها بالحرب
الدعائيه المدعومه من الخارج والميسره
الداخليا والتي اطلقت ضد قياده الجيش
وما تزال الملاحقات القضائيه التي يواجهها
عمران خان واعتقاله الاسبوع الماضي قبل
الافراج عنه يثير المزيد من ردود الفعل
وقد مثل خان مجددا امام محكمه لاهورا
العليا حيث يواجه اتهامات بالمسؤوليه عن
اعمال عنف ومواجهات حدثت عقب اعتقاله في
الاثناء نظم حزبان من الائتلاف الحاكم
مظاهره امام المحكمه العليا في العاصمه
اسلام ابادح احتجاجا على ما وصفوه
بالمعامله القضائيه التفضيليه لعمران خان
وطالب المتظاهرون رئيس القضاه في البلاد
بالاستقاله
معنى من اسلام اباد عيسى نبويه الاعلامي
والمحلل السياسي ومن اسلام اباد ايضا
سميره خان الصحفيه
والمحلله السياسيه اود ان ابدا معك سيد
نخوي عندما يقول الجيش انه لن يمارس ضبط
النفس بعد الان فما الذي نفهمه من هذا
الكلام
اعتقد ان
التصريح الذي ادلى به المسؤولون في الجيش
استخدم لهجه حاده للغايه وقويه للغايه وهو
يعبر عن ياسا سياسي وهناك رساله مباشره
وجهت الى الحزب الاساسي في البلاد الا وهو
حزب السيده عمران
وهناك محاوله
لتخويف الناس الذين تظاهروا دعما
للسيد عمران خان الذي يواجهه هذه
الملاحقات نحن نتحدث ايضا عن المدنيين
تعرضوا
للمضايقات وايضا تعرضوا
هناك حالات اعتقال وفيات للمدنيين بسبب
الجيش
السميره خان هل تعتقدين ان
اسلوب ما سماه ضيفنا نقوي التخويف يمكن ان
يكون ناجحا مع انصار عمران اخان الذين
يؤيدونه بقوه ويحرصون على اظهار ذلك بقوه
ايضا في الشارع في في باكستان وفي اسلام
اباد
الحقيقه اعتقد ان الرساله التي
وصلت بوضوح من الجيش الباكستاني طبعا اتت
بعد اجتماع للقيادات الامنيه والسياسيه
التي بحثت الاوضاع في البلاد كان هناك
تسليط الضوء
لمئه
حظي الامني والاستقرار في البلاد وما من
تساهلا بالنسبه الى اعمال الشغب التي
ترتكب من قبل اي طرف في المجتمع
الباكستاني وخصوصا عمليات التخريب التي
لحقت بالمنشات العسكريه التابعه للجيش
الباكستاني هذا امرا سوف يحاكم عليه
المرتكبون وهذا امر يؤدي الى احلال الاستق
في البلاد
والرساله وصلت بشكل واضح وصريح كل الاشخاص
الذين شاركوا في عمليات التخريب على
مشاربهم المختلفه سوف يحاكمون وفقا لما
ادلى به المسؤولون في الجيش الباكستاني
نحن نتحدث عن امر غير مسبوق نحن نرى هذا
للمره الاولى في باكستان ورد الفعل ايضا
الذي نشهده ايضا هو امر غير مسبوق في
الباكستانيه ان اعود للسيد نقوي هل هل
يعني يبدو لك هذا الكلام منطقيا سيدنا قوي
انه لن يسمح بالتخريب
كما يقول طرف الجيش وان اي شخص يقوم
باعمال تخريب غير قانونيه من حق الدوله ان
تحاسبه وسوف تحاسبه
بالنسبه الى اي شخص
يحاول ان يطبق القانون بيديه طبعا يجب ان
يحكم القانون في باكستان هناك صور متعدده
في حقيقه الامر وفيديوهات
متعدده طبعا
انتشرت كل من ارتكب يجب ان يحاكم ولكن
السؤال هل المحاكمات تكون عسكريه او
محاكمات مدنيه وفقا للاصول للمعتمده في
باكستان هذا هو السؤال الاساسي نتيجه لذلك
طبعا ما من احد يقول ان عمليات التخريب
يجب ان تمر من دون عقاب ولكن هناك دعوات
انتشرت في باكستان
لتحقيقات مستقله لان بعض الجهات ترى ان
هناك مندس سينا انت في اوساطه المجموعات
التي قامت بهذه العمليات التي صورت وهناك
تحريك لهذه النقطه ساطرحها على السيده
سميره السيده سميره هناك من يقول ان هذه
لعبه قديمه معروفه
السلطه عندما يخرج متظاهرون يكون هناك
مندسون يقومون باعمال شغب يكون هذا مبررا
لقمعهم بشده وفي الاساس المشكله السياسيه
ولا علاقه لها بهذه النقطه بالتحديد اذا
كان بامكانك ان تجيبي في دقيقه من فضلك
[موسيقى]
هناك من يقول ان هؤلاء مندسين ليبرروا
قمع المتظاهرين والهدف سياسي ليس اي شيء
اخر
اعتقد ان هناك نقاش ينتصر هنا في العاصمه
وانا تابعت هذا الموضوع منذ خمسه الى سته
ايام هناك
متعدده يجب ان تؤخذ بعين الاعتبار عند
تحليل الوضع في باكستان هو امرا غير مسبوق
ايضا التصريحات التي ادلى بها السيد عمران
خان والاضافه الى قيادات الحزب الحاكم كان
هناك ايضا الدعوات
للاشخاص لكي يخرجوا ويخربوا الان هناك بعض
الاشخاص والسياسيين الذين قاموا بهذه
الدعوات عادوا عن كلامهم وقالوا انه لم
يقوموا بالتحريض للقيام بعمليات التخريب
هذه لذلك يجب ان ناخذ هذا الوجه بعين
الاعتبار شكرا
جزيلا من اسلام اباد سميره خانه الصحفيه
والمحلله السياسيه وعيسى نقوي الاعلامي
والمحلل السياسي
[موسيقى]
اعلنت القوات الاوكرانيه انها حققت
انتصارات في مدينه باخموت وسيطرت على عشره
مواقع روسيه في ضواحيها اما
يفقينير فقد نفع ما نشرته
بشان اتصالاته مع المخابرات الاوكرانيه
وفي حين حصل الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي
على وعود بمساعدات عسكريه جديده نكرت نقلت
وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه عن مسؤول اوكراني
ان المنفذ الصينيه المكلفه بمناقشه تسويه
الحرب في اوكرانيا سيزورك الثلاثاء
والاربعاء
مدينه بخموت او ما تبقى منها اكثر من تسعه
اشهر من المعارك دون حسم استعصت المدينه
على الروس الذين لم يتمكنوا من اكمال
السيطره عليها رغم مجهود عسكري مرهق
الان تقول القوات الاوكرانيه انها تحقق
اول انتصاراتها في عمليه الدفاع عن بخموت
قائد القوات الارضيه الاوكرانيه اكد ان
قواته سيطرت على اكثر من عشره مواقع روسيه
في ضواحي بخموت اما روسيا فقد اعلنت ان
اثنين من قادتها العسكريين قتل في معارك
قرب المدينه تبعد بخمه
578 كيلومترا عن العاصمه كييف هي مدينه
صغيره لكنها تحولت الى رمز للصمود بالنسبه
للاوكرانيين ولذلك فاي انتصار فيها قبيل
الهجوم المضاد المتوقع سيعطي دفعه معنويه
كبيره للاوكرانيين
اما بالنسبه
للروسين قائد ميليشيا باجنر الذي يحارب
رجاله في الصفوف الاماميه تيباخمت سبب
كثيرا من الحرج للكرملين بتصريحاته انتقد
بريكوجين مرارا وزير الدفاع وقائد الاركان
الروسيين واتهمهما بتعمد عدم مد قواته
بالذخائر الان تنشر صحيفه واشنطن بوست ان
بريكوجين اجرى اتصالات مع المخابرات
الاوكرانيه وانه عرض عليها معلومات عن
مواقع الجيش الروسي مقابل انسحابي قوات
اوكرانيه من مواقع قرب بخموت نافا ما
نشرته الواشنطن بوست وقال انه مضحك واتهم
النخبه التي قال انها تسكن في احد الاحياء
الراقيه بموسكو بالوقوف وراء هذه
المعلومات يفضل بريكوجين توجيه سهام نقده
للنخب في موسكو على توجيهها للغرب الذي
يزود اوكرانيا بالعتاد الذي يستخدم غيرها
في لندن حيث استقبله رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني حسن الرئيس الاوكراني على
مساعدات بريطانيه جديده ضمنها مئات
الصواريخ الدفاعيه بالاضافه الى طائرات
مسيره يصل مداها الى اكثر من 200 كيلومتر
قبل لندن زرازيلنسكي روما وبرلين وباريس
وحصل على وعود بمساعدات المانيه بثلاثه
مليارات دولار ومساعدات عسكريه فرنسيه
وقال ان اخبارا عن تزويد بلاده بطائره
غربيه متطوره قريبه تبدو هذه الجوله كجزء
من الاستعداد للهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
الذي سيحتاج كثيرا من العتاد
[موسيقى]
نبقى في اوكرانيا مع اعلاني عواصم عده
تزويد بدفعات جديده من الاسلحه والسؤال
كيف تكيف الغرب مع احتياجات اوكرانيا
وتطورات الميدان منذ فبراير 2022 بعد
اندلاع الحرب وفي شهرين فبراير ومارس من
العمل الماضي تلقى الاوكرانيون من الغرب
اكثر من اربعين الف سلاح خفيف 17 الف منصه
دفاع محموله انظمه دفاع ارض جو محموله
بالاضافه الى 25 الف خوذه وسبعه عشره الف
ستره واقيه بل ثلاثين حتى ربما الف الستره
واقيه من الرصاص في فبراير في ابريل في
ابريل 2022 بدا تسليم اوكرانيا سلاح
المدفعيه مثل مدافع الهادر
وقاذفات الصواريخ وحتى الخريف تسلمت كييف
321 مدفع حوزر بما في ذلك مدفعا فرنسيا من
طراز قيصر ومئه وعشرين الف مركبه
ومئه وعشرين مركبه مشاه و49 قاذفه صواريخ
متعدده واربعه وعشرين طائره هليكوبتر
قتاليه واكثر من الف طائره بدون طيار
امريكيه بالاضافه الى 280
روسيا سلسله ضربات جويه سلمت الدول
الغربيه على راسها الولايات المتحده
والمملكه المتحده واسبانيا انضمت دفاع
مضاده للصواريخ لاوكرانيا وانتهى الامر
بموافقه واشنطن على تسليم كيف نظام صواريخ
ارض الجو الشهير في نهايه يناير من العام
الجاري اعلنت تواشنطن تسليم كييف دبابات
ابرامز بينما وعدت لندن بدبابات تشالنجر
اثنين وبرلين بليبارد اثنين المعروفه
بانها من الافضل في العالم وسمح الضوء
الاخضر الالماني بالدول الاخرى بتسليم
لبارد اثنين هذه هي الاسلحه وهنا تعهدات
في الجوله التي قام بها حاليا في اوروبا
خاصه من بريطانيا والمانيا وفرنسا كذلك مع
تبلور الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضد والمضاد
وفي ظل احجام الغرب عن تسليمه طائرات
مقاتله حديثه اذا بدا رئيس
الاوكرانيمير جولته الاوروبيه
في محاوله لتوسيع ترسانته في لندن حصل على
تعهد من بريطانيا بتسليم جيشه مئات
الصواريخ المضاده للطائرات والمسيرات
الهجوميه قريبا الرئيس الاوكراني اعرب عن
تفاعله في تسلم مقاتلات فيما يتعلق
بالمعدات العسكريه وحدها تعد لندن اول
الداعمين وثاني اكبر مزود لكييف مع تقديم
او منح مساعدات بقيمه 4.6 مليارات جنيه
استرليني في عامين 2022 23 الاحد
تعهدت فرنسا حيث التقى الرئيس المانيوال
ماكرون بتدريب عدد من الكتائب الاوكرانيه
وتجهيزها بعشرات المركبات المدرعه
والدبابات الخفيفه من طراز اي ام اكس 10
ار سي التي تستخدم غالبا في مهام
الاستطلاع وفي برلين اعلن المستشار
الالماني
خطه مساعدات عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا بقيمه
مليارين فاصل سبعه مليار اليورو قسم
العديد من الدبابات والعربات المدرعه
ومنظومات الدفاع المضاده للطائرات
نرحب
منجم
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي والضابط
السابق في المخابرات البريطانيه كما نرحب
من موسكو
الخبير العسكري والمختص في الشؤون النيتو
سيد فيليب انجرم الان هناك تعهد
بتزويد اوكرانيا بالعديد من الاسلحه
منها اسلحه هجوميه مسيرات هجوميه هناك من
يتهم دول الغرب بان هذا هدفه اطاله امد
الحرب هل هذا ما يحدث بالفعل وان لم يكن
الامر كذلك فما هو الهدف من تزويد كييف
بهذه الاسلحه
الهدف هو تقصير امد الحرب في حقيقه الامر
والطريقه الوحيده للقيام بذلك الا في حال
طبعا قرر الرئيس بوتين بان يسحب القوات
الروسيه من الاجزاء التي احتلها من
اوكرانيا بطريقه غير شرعيه اذا الطريقه
الوحيده فيما عدا ذلك هي ان تحصل اوكرانيا
على المعدات والعتاد التي هي بحاجه اليه
لكي تدفع القوات الروسيه خارجا لقد نجحت
القوات الاوكرانيه في الدفاع عن مواقعها
وفي صد الهجوم
الروسي والان هي في مرحله التجهيز الهجوم
المضاد سيد
الى اي مدى سوف تضر هذه الاسلحه بروسيا
في الواقع المسيرات الهجوميه التي
تستخدمها اوكرانيا او ممكن ان تستخدمها هي
ليست مشكله كبيره
لاوكرانيا ما يزعجنا ويقلقنا
وهذا ما لدينا اسئله كثيره عنه لان
الطائرات
وتوصيل بريطانيا هذه الطائرات اللي
اوكرانيا
وتسليمها لصواريخ مجنحه بعيده المدى وعليه
الدقه هذا قد يجعل روسيا تستخدم اسلحتها
ضد بريطانيا بشكل مباشر وهذا لا يفهمه
البريطانيون ستورم شيدو الصواريخ بعيده
المدى والتي ممكن ان تطلق عن طريق طائرات
او
او سفن النيتو ان استخدام مثل هذه
الطائرات او السفن
هذا يعني ان بريطانيا انضمت الى النزاع
وعلى هذا الاساس يجب على بريطانيا الحذر
العاصفه هذه هي دخلت بالفعل كما يبدو الى
المعركه كما يقول الروس لانهم قالوا انه
انهم اسقطوا احد هذه الصواريخ البريطانيه
ويقول ضيفنا ان هذا قد يجعل بريطانيا
مستهدفه بشكل مباشر من روسيا هل تعتقد ان
ذلك يمكن ان يحدث وكيف يمكن ان يحدث باي
وسيله يعني
كلا ابدا ان هذه الصواريخ صواريخ ظل
العاصفه تم تقديمها ودمجها من خلال عمليه
بسيطه لكي تستخدم من قبل
الاوكرانيين ان الصواريخ تحلق بطريقه
مستقله نحن نتحدث عن الصواريخ مجنحه
والدفعات الجويه الروسيه يمكنها ان تسقطها
لقد صممت لتخطي الدفاعات ولكن ولا اي سلاح
يمكن ان يكون دقيقا 100% ولكن نحن نعرف ان
لهذه الصواريخ الواقعه النفسي
والانسانيه الكبير وهذا يعني ان القوات
الاوكرانيه باستطاعتها ان تستهدف القوات
الروسيه في اماكن متعدده في
المناطق التي تحيط بالجسور الاساسيه وهذا
امر اساسي للقوات الاوكرانيه قبل البدايه
بدايه العمليه المضاده وهو تعزيز كبير
للقدرات العسكريه الاوكرانيه كل ما لدى
روسيا داخل الحدود الدوليه المعترف بها
لاوكرانيا هو هدف الان للقوات الاوكرانيه
هناك اسلحه مثل ستورم شادو او اسلحه اخرى
واوكرانيا تستعد لهجوم مضاد سيد ارتامن
اوف هل الروس مستعدون عسكريا لهذا الهجوم
باسقاط صواريخ
شادو منذ الان يجب ان انبه ان هذه صواريخ
اصابت مواقع مدنيه في لوغاسكو
مصنعا للحمد لله الحمد انه لم يكن هناك
احد
واصابت معهدا دراسيا حيث لم يتواجد اي
عسكريين هذه معلومات اعترف بها
الاوكرانيين لذلك
القوات الروسيه لا تخشى هذه الصواريخ هذه
الصواريخ تصيب المدن المدنيه والمواقع
المدنيه وهذا عيب وفضيحه للبريطانيين انهم
لا يهددون القوات الروسيه بل هم يفجرون
المواقع المدنيه واجب التاكد من المعلومات
قبل نشرها على العلم
شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك من موكسو من موسكو
الكسندر ارتامونوف الخبير العسكري والمختص
في شؤون النيتو وكذلك
اشكر فيليب انجرن الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي والضابط السابق في المخابرات
البريطانيه التي كان معنا من بامكان
[موسيقى]
سترات سوداء كتب عليها النكبه اصل الروايه
والعوده حق ورايات سود كتب عليها العوده
بالعربيه والانجليزيه ورسم عليها مفتاح
قديم هذا جانب من احياء الاف الفلسطينيين
الذكرى الخامسه والسبعين للنكبه تحت عنوان
يوم استقلالكم يوم نكبتنا يحرص
الفلسطينيون على المشاركه في هذه الذكرى
للتاكيد على ان حق العوده لا يسقط
بالتقادم بجميع الذين هجروا من ارضهم
ومنازلهم وبحسب ارقام الامم المتحده فان
5.9 ملايين لاجئ فلسطيني يتوزعون اليوم
بين الضفه الغربيه المحتله وقطاع غزه
والاردن ولبنان وسوريا قله منهم لا تزال
على قيد الحياه من اصل سبعمائه وستين الف
فلسطيني هجروا من منازلهم في حرب عام
1948 والتي اندلعت اثره قيام دوله
لاسرائيل
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]